hi
i'm susan carlucci and this is your one
minute monday my message today is to
just really try to focus on making your
customers say
wow it's very simple premise but i have
found over the years i've been an
entrepreneur for
more than 25 years and i consistently
think of that when
times are difficult or or they're
flowing to make them say wow so my
example would be if they
like i had a clothing store in yorkville
in the toronto area and when customers
would come in
i would kind of listen to what they're
interested in but then whatever it was
in terms of the service that i was
giving them i would pause a minute and i
would try to think of something
that was just a little bit above the
expectation of what they asked me and
try to deliver something that was just
like spectacularly beyond that and
prompting them to say well
it's a very simple simple idea but i
think it kind of engages people in
in passion and they realize that you're
very interested in them and you're going
to deliver
just a little bit more than what they're
asking for so
it's very simple idea but that's my
message today about trying to make your
customers consistently say wow
when they have an interaction with you
and your business and that's it have a
great monday
you